in 2015 the Calgary underground Film
Festival added a number of video games
to the festival lineup now in 2016
cuff Cade returns for a second year in a
row we stopped by and asked a couple
developers how they feel about cupcake
tough kids awesome such a bucket list
kind of thing I think for everyone that
makes video games it's like to put it
into a cabinet some days because I don't
interact so it's a bit overwhelming to
see people playing it like enjoying it
no it's definitely a bucket list thing
to see your game at first you're like oh
it will be fine I'm not really gonna
react at all you're like wow they're
really into it so it's I guess it should
talk you if you're working really hard
on it but it always says it's
interesting cuz I think both of our
games are actually more suited for like
a gamepad sort of like a dual axis kind
of thing so you have to make some
concessions with the arcade cabinet so
well the game is mostly made for like
keyword in math so it was really
challenging for our developers to get a
for the controller and arcade controller
you can't like woo than aim at the same
time kind of deal
and has to be like shorts and quake for
people to play it right
taking a game of playing it under couch
you have a lot more time to play it then
and arcade cabinet before you can go see
a movie at cupcake so some of that stuff
you have to keep in mind so I mean it's
good to see it in public because you
don't really know how people like
because people can say something online
but they seem something else and you can
kind of see where people are having
trouble and it's nice to see live
feedback interaction because what
somebody waits to tell you sometimes
they can kind of change what about the
game seeing someone's frustration level
is very good because he do exactly when
they're hitting that point where you
need to adjust something you know I
think Calgary has like a super healthy
community that's growing and you're
trying to really do something at a
grassroots level here it's only gonna go
up
I think we're we're starting to like
reach the boiling points like the talent
is here and we're just picturing as a
seed so it's just a matter of time I
think before some successful successful
gates start coming out of Calgary you
just got to work really hard at this and
you know put yourself out there people
will see your game and if you throw
things I'm making it fun people play it
especially in a place like this it's
more open and try it if people are
willing to try then like maybe if they
saw it online they might not it's not
live kind of like a live let's play yeah
so through 200 it's will be out in this
summer sometime on PC Mac and actually
Xbox console pass one or two thousand
will be available on Steam PC and Mac
yeah we're both our games are already
Greenland and stuff along with seed
scape and SEM aspheres paradise perfect
I think this we know it already for a
little while so a lot of these games are
be available to eat over just hopefully
soon so if you want to check out cup
Kade you can find it on the mezzanine
level of the globe cinema for the
remainder of the Calgary underground
Film Festival